[Music]
in let us help news lettuce submitted by
wide awoke why to woke oh that's it a
new startup claims to help with the
logistical nightmare of a breakup yeah
raiding all your stuff pretty much yeah
that's dull I know is a genius idea
hunting Alice yeah yeah exactly
apartment hunting [ __ ] [ __ ] way
how do you cut taiga in half hey you
visitation it's much more yeah we're in
the 20th century though I thought you
scissors
that's an old way these to do it you're
thinking of the traditional way yeah
what happens if you're dating and they
pay half the rent but your name is the
one on the lease cuz they moved in with
you and then they break up then you guys
break up and then they don't pay the
rent anymore and you're like [ __ ] on
rent do they deal with that maybe that's
what the apps for they deal with all the
complicated stuff yeah or do they just
send someone to hug you I'm sorry yeah
sorry yeah we're just here to hug you
today you're pretty much sure we're
gonna get a big this thing yeah and your
credits gonna go bad yeah yep so this
company here it's called onward and it's
a new on-demand service that helps
people pack find housing move out that's
cool so they have three different types
of packages so the first one is $99 the
rebound package mm-hmm when they find
you a bunch of hot chicks to move in to
move in with I love hauling your snare
the guy always gets dumped because it
always happens that way that's what it
always is young yeah so this this
service as of right now is only for New
York City but they're planning on
expanding to more cities such a cool
idea um so the $99 package it offers a
10-day plan for short and long term
housing such as a hotel Airbnb a new
apartment or cool living space along
with options and discounts for storage
moving services pecking and access to
events to help singles beef up their
social calendars via the 30 day package
is 100
$25.00 it helps people furnish their new
homes and then have someone assist with
address and utility changes and get
discounts on moving company all for 99
bucks well no now I moved on to the
South I'm still very cheap I didn't even
break up with Jess and I want somebody
to just do this because I was I'm doing
that [ __ ] right now yeah and then the
$500 package
yes yeah furnish your new house 170
bucks
so for the five hundred dollar package
it will find you new housing assemble
furniture for you in your new house
assemble what the [ __ ]
can we - even if we're not breaking out
can't you even why I love assembling
furniture if you ever need that buy me a
bottle of wine really I'll just drink
wine and assemble furniture that's my
favorite it's my favorite thing do you
guys like unpacking things from boxes
and putting it away no I need to find
somebody to do that but they don't know
what a putting service I can send you a
service and you do it for you y'all and
they organized it and it looks sick
that's cool that's nice we need to do
that anyway I love that you should Marie
Kondo right now all your [ __ ] is I did
it before yeah they did it before they
was good mannequin doll
to get rid of some I don't want like joy
it's a magic wand oh that's right
doesn't it you should watch it on
Netflix does it the speck of joy no bit
messy was gonna come watch it with me
and then he didn't I tried to walk in I
was watching I was watching over your
shoulder it was so [ __ ] boring I had
to leave the room you know what I got
the audiobook of her book and then so
audiobook of her book and when we were
having dinner the other night I played
it and I told Casey and Isaac I'm like
listen guys this is very important to me
can you please listen to this book with
me because you guys we need all be on
the same page I'm tired of being the
only one that cares about the organized
house you guys gotta get on board with
me and so we were eating dinner and like
they're just like yeah I predict
watch the Netflix 1 it's more
entertaining it doesn't show you how to
how did you could do that you could just
memorize no the book is the book is so
much easier to to read and figure out
how to do it because she blocked out
lines it exactly like first start with
clothes and then she tells you exactly
what to do with the clothes and how to
feel them and also nothing yet but just
for the stuff that we listen to she was
just talking about likewise Heidi yeah
important I'm like you need to listen to
this yeah that book was made the books
way better than this series because it
outlines why you should do it and then
it outlines how and I like that it's
like why should you do it and then tell
me how why should you do yeah watch
happier you you appreciate your things
more you want to tidy because you're
only keeping things that you value and
that you that bring you joy so you want
them to stay nice and you're thinking it
each time soon I think we're ever ething
is energy you know that no no I know but
it's just weird does it be like I am
thankful for you to I guess I am
thankful for trading it away like you're
like hey purse thanks for being a purse
today and holding my thing in tension
yes I always play with my [ __ ] oh so
funny that's also get in trouble for
taking too long cuz like if I'm like
putting something away like if I'm like
taking a gun out my face I might that's
exactly what I and then at three hours
past buyers players all my good name as
a kid that's pretty good and then you're
filling your garage with water she can
softball in your garage no but then I
like it too she was talking about she
was pinpointing how like it's
interesting that like are the three main
things that we need is like food the
shelter or not that we need sorry that
people are really interested in [ __ ] I
forgot I'm butchering it forget it just
read the book yeah talk about yeah I
read it twice altar is never something
that's hot but like you know people
learn about food like how to cook and
stuff and then
I like food but you're not taught how to
tidy and how to keep get to but I've put
in here I wish tip was on lecture shirk
lecture circuit she just comes out and
she's like okay part of the charm zone I
just love it cuz I was really stoned I
was like okay yeah no-one's interrupting
her but she's so used to getting
interrupted she's like wait no is it
interrupt me
exactly I honestly do if you have those
thoughts like way in the back I'm like
whoa everyone's listening to me now oh
my god could you get the thing that you
want to say oh it's not coming out way
better or interrupting you
yeah you have time to think of the next
thing you're gonna say I'm not thinking
that's the thing as I panic gonna give
up gonna be wait I was in the middle of
telling you guys the five hundred dollar
plan yeah so there's some blurry
furniture if I knew housing they
customized new neighborhood guides with
recommendation holy [ __ ] this is also my
yard
Jim stole how any housing is really hard
yeah because it's new New York City do
that it's probably hot over there and
then it also gives you um well with
these recommendations also access to
self-care options such as therapy or
lawyers 504 505 a three-month period oh
yeah Wow
yes where were they when we were moving
do let's go break up or when I was
living in a [ __ ] closet I just needed
a place to live yeah I had to move into
that closet because I was the next
girlfriend
mm it was terrible it's something like
this but when we got married but it
wasn't this extensive it was like you
know we have to leave it like why I
changed my last name to his so that
meant I had to change everything shut up
so I had to change everything and I'm
like [ __ ] what is that everything entail
so I just pay like 100 bucks and then
they just sent me oh yeah I got that the
hitch switch
since all that stuff right there's
another one oh yeah and then like I just
felt but I still had to do it myself to
show up to the DMV you still to go there
yeah that's dumb why I'm gonna still go
cuz it cuz yeah you thought to do
everything yourself to just give me
other paperwork but they didn't feel
like you fill it out online and they
fill it in to the paper form oh yeah I
would change my name if it was to
something way sicker well I want to just
change Steve's name to green but take
the e off the end just so we had to go
through the same processes like you can
keep your name but just take the e off
and change the cue yeah yeah it's cute
you'd still get you'd actually probably
get more hits because everyone forgets
to put the e on anyway so yes search or
just add R at the end Steve greener oh
that's pretty good but yeah so this
company here was created by childhood
friends named Lindsay and Mika who are
34 and 33 years old and they always be
breaking up Oh what if they hope a guy
move in with his mistress that's [ __ ]
up
and then they don't think the business
because they're in the business of
breakups are helping the meanwhile will
they want divorce they want strife they
want undo oh my god there's so they're
saying they're two evil doers something
that's like it's gonna happen anyway
might as well be a service for ya which
is good they started this company after
they both suffered break up their own
six months apart so you're gonna say
that after they both broke up they're
like hey we could start a business out
of this not together but they have a
business and then they had a bad breakup
and they were fighting over who's gonna
keep the dog pictures let's move out and
restart our entire lives and so we were
seeing that there's a lot of
similarities between emotional
logistical turmoil of it all
so they were just they just thought of
the site this idea for this company
that's awesome launched on Valentine's
Day in New York and they said they
received almost a hundred enquiries
that's amazing it's a really good start
it's a good dump tanks were evenly split
between men and women aged 25 to 4 it's
amazing yeah you plan to roll out to LA
San Francisco Chicago and DC it's the
best businesses are all around tragedy
yeah and fake celebration yeah
weddings a cute weddings you do a
tragedy or a fake celebration I know
well wedding celebration they're kind of
fake sometimes in the way that people
try to do the most elaborate freaking
wedding but they don't have any real
love there they're just like they're
more into the wedding that they're into
use the courthouse right like that's the
celebrate that's what I'm saying that if
you spend like 60 G's that's the fake
celebration price Karma that's what I'm
saying yeah 60 G's it's not any
tragedies or anything over a gene
operations a celebration part of it that
people have social pressures for all
that [ __ ] it's true
yep and mini-golfing he's a great
business also mini-golfing but unrelated
just a great business baby
that's cute please to probably if you
add it with gold card exactly I was
gonna say that
Ringo's arts mini-golf you're at the
apex of all and bumper boats you got a
half ball I love bumper ball I'm an
boats I love going there because I like
to hit the kids with the bumper boat
yours alone
we're in Florida um what was that place
word oh yeah like a speed zone oh yeah
it was a bit like there was one where it
was like us too he like unde ready yeah
he hits me I'm a bug I spin out and then
I'm the kid in front of him now and then
he did the same [ __ ] to the kids do that
I'm here to give a [ __ ] he wanted to win
I loved doing that at the go-kart track
dude I was losing my mind doing go-kart
I was yelling I want to go fast the
whole time at the top of my lungs
you gotta go faster just the tops I know
I was just trying I was just trying to
protest those I don't want to go fast I
want to go [ __ ] announcing over the
thing like you believe that it would
have Joel dude I would have I remember
going to the k1 speed racing here in
Aloha site yeah it was super fun but my
boyfriend it's an ex-boyfriend he kept
winning and I got pissed that he kept
winning so then I like like got this
tactic down the strategy down and then I
kept like getting first every time and I
was like haha I wouldn't leave until I
could be that is very Nikki it is a joy
to joy to hobby with you and this dude
he wasn't even cocky about it either
I was just biggest he wasn't cocky buddy
no you gotta be coffee about everything
do i school this chicken you I want the
challenge dude in laser tag I'm [ __ ]
Rambo and laser tag yeah no you are
really good at laser tag that pissed me
off so yeah I'm [ __ ] recognizable
dude I'm in there like I'm insane and
even a little Mexican and Chinese kids
in there they can't handle me I come out
of nowhere then they'll I feel like it's
the [ __ ] White Buffalo